kobe bryant's widow and that 16 million  award from her lawsuit over the graphic  photos of her husband and daughter's  bodies vanessa bryant will reportedly  donate the payout to the non-profit of  mama and mama cedar sports foundation  kobe bryant created that foundation back  in 2016 to offer sports education to  underserved athletes on wednesday you  might remember a jury found that the l.a  county sheriff's office and the fire  department were liable for distress  caused by photos that first responders  took and then shared after the chopper  crash that killed kobe and gianna bryan  and seven others back in 2020.  you know she at the beginning of this  trial said she would donate to charity  because she really wanted to make it  clear that it was not about the money it  was strictly about making sure those  photos did not get out and that it  didn't happen to anybody else